ever since i was 13 been smoking weed um
and it's definitely an area of my life
that
you know nothing wrong with it but it's
an area in my life i want to grow in
because i can tell it's definitely
taking a strong grip um oh yeah
weedle uh
it's comfortable it's comfortable
it's like walking around with a you know
just a pillow just you know
party it's like a pillow party hey
i'm having fun my brain's kind of fun
looks cool looks cool out here what's
going on
oh i lost my job
oh
oh all right
oh dunkin donuts
you know that's weed let's hear it
my life you know and um i definitely
don't know how it is in louisiana i was
wondering
out there in louisiana man what does it
look like dealing with the people who
are always stoned do you even see them
well look brother i'll tell you this man
i grew up in louisiana and it's a
beautiful place dude if you believe in
beauty then you uh you believe in that
state
and it's one of the top 50 states and
it's
louisiana purchase we did that
so
half y'all would be canadian if we
hadn't done the deal
you're welcome
but i want to say this i remember weed
was fun
weed was fun back in the day you know
you get that swamp gas baby start
huffing it up
and that [ __ ] was brown bro some of it
had a damn gator claw in it or a damn
little falcon half a falcon nut in that
bastard we louisiana weed baby damn
that thing bro you take a hit of it and
the water level in your yard would rise
that [ __ ]
and say what thick boy that [ __ ] was
you know that thing dude you damn
i mean they had just trimmed baby that
[ __ ] was that [ __ ] you know
that [ __ ] that
they trimmed those reggie bushes bro and
you hit that slam jordan dawg you know
what i'm saying baby that [ __ ] was south
and i love getting high as a child was
great i don't care where you were
you know uh
dude i
i remember the weed you get a bag of
weed on it and if you didn't want to uh
smoke it they'd have a damn recipe for
you oh let's make you a little bit of a2
faded you know
some um
you know get you a little bit of uh just
that gumbo
just that freaking get your brains all
you know
get you have your brain just [ __ ]
looking for itself bruh
you know you could feel your brain
looking for itself dog that should get
you gassed up
that [ __ ] will have you singing the
national anthem bruh
at a um
that shit'll have you singing a national
anthem to a spice rack dog that's that
louisiana swamp gas
yeah getting high in louisiana was fun
man as a child and getting high anywhere
as a child is great if you can do it do
it then and do it well
and do it high
and i remember we used to be over at my
buddy's house and um
we used to get high over there
and his daddy wasn't super his daddy
wasn't super fond of gays at the time he
didn't he wasn't anti-gay he just didn't
know anything about it and it made him
real uncomfortable
um so me and my friend and my other
friend we go outside we smoke weed i'd
come back in early to the house i'd be
the first one back in and i would go to
my buddy's dad i would know about that
kind of gay trigger he had
and i would just tell him i'd like hey
mr mike you know uh
you know they were kind of being a
little
i don't know what they were doing sir
they just
i saw him kind of like
you know once somebody took their shirt
off for no reason outside i just some of
this stuff was just
made me uncomfortable right
so then my two buddies would come back
into the house stoned out the gills baby
i mean just [ __ ] fish food and baby
they wasn't doing well
and now suddenly my buddy's dad is
grilling them about being gay and they
don't know that i told the uh the dad
the stuff so
i used to love that kind of [ __ ] man
create an ambiance
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one